what was the kind of progression that we
had a look at arithmetic very good so
this is our first one in here and what's
going to proceed from here stuff that we
established over the last two lessons so
firstly how do you make an arithmetic
progression how do you go from one term
to the next what do you do what
operation do you do you add and
specifically what you add is a common
difference very good and because it's a
common difference we call that value we
call it d4 difference no big deal okay
now if you get given a progression of
some kind and they say hey can you prove
that that is an arithmetic progression
there's something that you can state an
equality you can state that connects to
this if you can show that this is true
it will definitely be an arithmetic
progression does anyone remember it's
right back at the definition of what an
AP is I'll give you a clue it starts
with the T here you go ahead t2 minus t1
so I'm just going to pause there right
so what we're looking at is two
consecutive terms and if you look at
that difference what do we want that to
be equal to t3 minus t2 which which in
turn should be that common difference
they should be the same thing right and
naturally we could continue this for the
rest of the terms turn 3 turn 4 2 and 5
etc but really this is all you need to
establish it okay now we developed some
formulas yesterday we did this one but
finally cast your mind back this is t2
t1 t3 what's T and what's our formula
for this when it comes to an arithmetic
progression max do you remember it no
it's someone else ok we'll start with an
A and then doing a finish yourself
you're good yeah what are we gonna what
are we gonna what operation doing in
here there's a plus sign right it's a
plus sign and then I what's what's with
the ends right n minus 1 times that
common difference could you remember
that what was it n minus 1 by the way
I'm trying to remember why is it N minus
1
yeah you don't add any lots of that
common difference to the first term if
you only think about this way
what's t1 t1 is a plus 0 term 1 is a
after all okay now
the most recent thing we had to have a
look at some pictures animations for
this if you want to do the sum or the
first n terms firstly how do we write it
by the way oh okay you're going straight
to the formula so first we generally say
s for sum right and we did say we did
establish two different ways to actually
write it now Sarang you've actually
begun kind of in the middle of one of
them I'm gonna write down the two a but
yeah there's a half out of photos more
than just the half isn't there there's
an N on - can we finish the rest of this
it's very similar what we've already got
plus plus that right plus this now this
was actually not the first formula that
we came up with there's a simpler one
that came before it was this thing with
first and last term's Edison can you
fills in fantastic so a plus our
indicating your first term your last
term okay now remember these two are the
same thing just dressed up differently
so we use both of them in order to be
able to say do you have the last term or
just just use this formula if you know
if you don't know what the last time is
when they use this formula okay you use
it according to what is appropriate
alright so this is what happens when
you're adding a common difference but
this is not the only kind of progression
that we're interested in okay the other
thing we're actually gonna spend much
more time on this than the other has got
more interesting applications it's not
what we call them athletic progression
it's called a geometric progression okay
so instead of going for one turn to the
next by adding what's another operation
we could use
yeah multiplication right someone did
say - but subtraction is kind of like
addition but backwards I guess if you
added a common difference that was
negative you'd have that effect okay so
let's think about this when you multiply
to get from one term to the next right
you wouldn't call that a common
difference between the terms we would
call that right
and a common difference we would call it
a common ratio so no surprises - guess
what letter we tend to indicate that
with I love you said day because it is
over there we usually use our yeah
alpha ratio okay now think about this
for a second I'll just write a quick
example on the board if I had a sequence
like two and then six and then I guess
18 and so on right if I'm telling you
that's a geometric progression I've got
a common ratio of what by the way in
this case three because I'm multiplying
by 3 H time how do I prove that how do I
actually show it in a way that's sort of
analogous to this it's not gonna have to
do with subtraction what am I gonna do
strain very good so instead of I'm doing
addition with subtraction I'm going to
undo multiplication with division right
so we divide when I take that ratio what
should it be equal to it should be equal
to the common ratio but I'll name that
based on based on the rest of the ratios
that I also observe so they should be
the same and we would call that R okay
now let's think about this for a second
coming back to this to 618 example that
I just kind of pulled out of thin air if
we call the first term - and our common
ratio in this case would be what do we
say what's 3 in this case I could write
the next term as a times 3 do you agree
with that and then I could write the
next term is a times 3 times 3 because
I've got to take that and multiply by 3
again now we're lazy we don't like doing
it like that so we're just going to use
the index notation that's what it's for
right ok now just like before do you
notice how many threes are there here
it's the third term and it's got two
threes how many threes are there here
it's the second term but there's there's
one lot of the ratio and then how many
threes are here that none of them right
it's it's
yeah and minus one it's the same thing
we saw before right
except turn man it's not a and then you
add some stuff it's a and then you
multiply so in fact I'm not even gonna
write anything I multiplied by some
number of the common ratio how many it's
always one less one less than what you
had which is like we said what we know
to see sets to the power of M minus one
so far so good
you're okay there all right now I'm not
going to have a look at this just yet
this takes a bit more thought to develop
but all of this stuff that you just
identified this is kind of like a little
playground that you can work with in
just like we saw things and applications
of arithmetic progressions we can do the
same with geometric progressions a lot
of the applications we're gonna see how
to do with money some of them have to do
is just look through the window in a
second for the for a second out there
every time light passes through that
window a little bit of light is
reflected back out not much cuz they're
clear windows but but a little bit right
either reflected or absorbed if I had a
whole bunch of panes of glass and in
fact you can look all the way through
till I a few more panes of class through
there you see a percentage of light gets
reduced every time you might start with
like say a hundred percent of the light
and then the next one through you only
get ten percent less than that right and
then you get ten percent less than that
and then you get ten percent less than
my arithmetic sign to struggle it's
going to be seventy two point something
or other okay so you can see here these
quantities are getting smaller not by
addition or subtraction but by division
you following